the fallout continues from dave
chappelle's netflix comedy special where
he uh
dared to crack one or two jokes at the
expense of the lgbt alphabet squad
most recently the showrunner for
netflix's anti-white series called dear
white people
says that he who identifies now as a she
will be boycotting the network by the
way this showrunner who now goes by
jacqueline moore
is white so this is a white man who
identifies as a woman and makes an
anti-white show about black people
boycotting a black man for telling jokes
about trans people it's a it is a
tangled web of intersectionality there
here's what variety reports they say uh
quote jacqueline moore has always
considered dave chappelle one of her
comic heroes
quote his shadow is huge says moore who
was a writer and showrunner on netflix's
dear white people he's a brilliant goofy
comedian he's brilliant as a political
comedian he's been brilliant for so so
long but i also don't think
uh because you've been brilliant means
that you're always brilliant
after the chappelle special i can't do
this anymore i won't work for netflix
again as long as they keep promoting and
profiting from dangerous transphobic
content
uh
she also tweeted
sheik in quotes here i'm reading from
the variety that's what the word they're
using i love so many of the people i've
worked with at netflix brilliant people
and executives who have been
collaborative and fought for important
art but i've been thrown against walls
because i'm not a real woman
i've had beer bottles thrown at me so
netflix i'm done
we should note that moore apparently
according to variety transitioned into a
woman
during the pandemic so you know in the
last several months
and already he's incensed at the
suggestion that he's not a real woman
there have been many other reactions
along these lines glaad for example uh
released a statement saying
uh dave chappelle's brand has been
synonymous with ridiculing trans people
and other marginalized communities
negative reviews and viewers loudly
condemning his latest special is a
message to the industry that audience
audiences don't support platforming
anti-lgbtq diatribes we agree
at an lgbt group called the national
black justice coalition weighed in
saying
with 2021 on track to be the deadliest
year on record for transgender people in
the u.s the majority of whom are black
transgender people netflix should know
better perpetuating transphobia
perpetuates violence netflix should
immediately pull the closer from its
platform and directly apologize to the
transgender community
of course the claim that there's some
kind of epidemic of anti-trans murders
much less that these murders are
propelled by comedy specials
is uh pure fiction
the vast majority of trans murderers are
drug or prostitution related or they're
due to domestic violence
um but the lgbt lobby you know
reflexively lies about everything
so this is to be expected
the media has likewise been breathless
in its condemnations here's the headline
from npr says for dave chappelle punch
lines are dares
but his new special the closer goes too
far
and from the hill chappelle called out
for hostile transphobia and homophobia
in netflix special
and the guardian says dave chappelle
ricky gervais and comedy's ironic
bigotry problem
and the daily beast dave chappelle's
pointless transphobia and homophobia and
so on
now before we continue it probably makes
sense to actually listen to the segments
of the special that have provoked all of
this ire uh there are primarily two that
seem to have to have caused all this
trouble the first we played a few days
ago i'll play it again just to remind
you here is uh chappelle
pointing out that when it comes to
deciding what to be offended by we seem
to have our priorities a bit out of
whack
in our culture let's listen a lot of the
lgbtq community doesn't know the baby's
history he's a wild guy
he once shot
and killed him
in walmart
oh this is true google it the baby shot
and killed in walmart north carolina
nothing bad happened to his career
do you see where i'm going with this
in our country you can shoot and kill
but you better not hurt a gay person's
feelings
[Music]
i guess i should have clarified
it's a bit of setup there was probably
necessary that he's talking about a
rapper named the baby he's not referring
to an actual baby
who shot and killed someone at walmart
uh though i i you know i think i have
seen babies walking around with handguns
at walmart um but this is a rapper his
name is the baby and in fairness the
baby um who you know of course i'm a big
fan of of all of his work
um says he says that he shot the the guy
in self-defense
in in the walmart um
the guy was trying to rob him in the
middle of a walmart and shot yeah i
don't know i don't know if he did or
didn't
but i do know that the baby brags in his
music about murdering people all the
time i mean he like most rappers
glorifies
murder drug dealing violent crime and so
on
so even if he hadn't actually killed a
guy himself still it would seem
far more offensive to promote actual
murder
than to make insulting comments about
gays
so the point from chappelle stands no
matter the particulars of
that case there at walmart
but i think it's chappelle's comments
about gender and trans people that have
gotten most of the attention
and have caused most of the uh the
backlash of people calling for him to be
to be cancelled and here they are here
you canceled jk rowling my god jk
rowling wrote all the harry potter books
by herself
she sold so many books the bible worries
about him
and it canceled her because she said in
an interview and this is not exactly
what she said but effectually she said
gender was a fact
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf
i didn't even know what that was
but i know that
trans people make up words to win
arguments
so i looked it up
turf is an acronym
stands for trans-exclusionary radical
feminists this is a real thing this is a
group of women
that hate transgender they don't hate
transgender women but they look at trans
women the way we blacks might look at
blackface it offends them like
she's doing an impression of me
look at it like this caitlyn jenner whom
i've met wonderful person caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year her first year as a
woman ain't that something beat
everybody in detroit she's better than
all of you
gender is a fact this is a fact every
human being in this room every human
being on earth had to pass through the
legs of a woman to be on earth that is
a fact
uh now
a couple of points in fact you notice
one thing that kind of stands out
uh
even in the context of making
the points that he makes here
he's still respecting the pronouns right
he still calls caitlyn jenner her in a
sheet
and that's what you find that that it's
it's so rare
even the people who are willing and it
takes guts to do it i give them credit
for it
so i'm not trying to take anything away
from her split hairs here but
it's not really splitting hairs
even the people who are willing to stand
up
and point out
some of the truth
and um cr you know and and make some of
these criticisms
most of them are not willing to go all
the way very few people very few
are willing to go all the way on this
and totally reject
left-wing gender ideology completely
there are very few people willing to do
that
um a couple other points first you know
chappelle has made jokes about all
different groups and demographics
he jokes about white people all the time
uh he's a comedian that's what comedians
are supposed to do
most of the people offended by the two
clips i just played would not be
offended and have not been offended by
any of his jokes about literally any
other group of people
none of them
should the alphabet squad really be
exempt from all mockery should they be
the one single group that nobody ever
makes fun of
the answer according to his critics
is yes
that's that is their answer you can make
fun of anybody just not them
and the reason they give for that is
that they say that uh attacking lgbt
people
or or not even attacking but making
jokes about them is uh punching down
it's punching down but the actual reason
is exactly the opposite of that
you know there's that old saying i don't
remember who who coined it originally
but that you can tell who has the power
in any society based on who you're not
allowed to criticize
and that's a rule that will rarely steer
you wrong and it certainly does not here
the reason you can criticize everybody
except lgbt people is that they hold the
cultural power
you get canceled for making jokes about
the alphabet squad simply because the
alphabet squad has the power to cancel
people
they they're the ones who can do it they
can they could chew they could choose to
tolerate such mockery or not and they
certainly choose not to because you're
not going to find much in the way of
self-deprecating humility among lgbt
leftists or among any any form of
leftist
um
when it comes to leftism narcissism is
part of the game and a narcissist is not
going to be happy with you making any
jokes about them at all
corporate america
the media
academia
the government
school system hollywood
all
bow in
service bow in submission to the lgbt
lobby
all are largely run by the lgbt lobby
we're told that lgbt people are
marginalized
but if you want to know what
marginalized actually means and what it
looks like
then look at lgbt
and imagine the precise opposite of that
they have way outsized influence and
power relative to their numbers
that's not what marginalized means you
don't marginalize this you know you know
who the marginalized people are
the people who listen to that last
segment from chappelle and agree with it
they're the marginalized ones
the people who know that biological sex
is a fact
the people who know that only women give
birth
and who would prefer to live in a
society that recognizes that fact
and a society that uh that
cherishes women and femininity
because it is unique and special
and not anyone can partake in it just
because they identify with it in their
heads
those are the people who are
marginalized
and how do you know they're marginalized
because they're in the majority
but their influence
is way undersized
relative to their numbers
that's what it means to be marginalized
it means you're pushed to the peripheral
it means that you're ignored
okay when you're ignored and pushed to
the peripheral you're being marginalized
who could anyone with a straight face
well they can
apparently
uh but it's it's kind of mind-boggling
that they can with a straight face that
anyone with a stray face could claim
that lgbt people are marginalized
pushed to the peripheral
ignored
really
i mean they get their own month and i
think we're in the middle of another
month right now because right now i
believe is lgbt history month i could be
wrong so you know every month in some
ways a celebration
again the opposite of marginalized
marginalized are the people
who agree with dave chappelle there
they're being marginalized
and that's exactly why even though what
chappelle is saying especially the very
end
that everybody who's on earth today or
has ever been born
had to pass through a woman in order to
be born
like i said yesterday
if someone had told you back in 2000
like 20 years ago
you know if you could have looked into
the future if you were
flipping through the channels and
stumbled on
a channel that was broadcasting from 20
years in the future and you saw that
segment and someone told you that that
would be considered controversial 20
years from now
you would be filled with with you
wouldn't believe it and you but if you
did you'd be filled with dread and
terror right like are you so we you're
saying society completely loses its mind
well yeah
in the future
but the reason why it becomes kind of a
big deal
is because the vast majority of people
recognize that this is true
that biological sex is a fact
uses the word gender there really what
he means is biological sex gender is a
you know gender as it relates to people
is an invention
um
biological sex is a fact only women give
birth like this this is something that
everyone recognizes most people the vast
majority
and the reason why
you know they celebrate something like
dave chappelle
is because a lot of people even though
they recognize these basic truths
they've been they've been pushed to the
margins
and now they feel like they need
permission
they need someone who's in the
mainstream some prominent person
to say whatever what what they all
recognize to be true
[Music]
and it's sad that people are waiting for
permission to speak basic truths
[Music]
but that's where we are and that's what
it means to be marginalized
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated